Speaker 1: Let's go next to Alex from
Baltimore, Maryland. Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David didn't hear me. I can.
Speaker 7: Hey, great, so I have a question about
moderates in general, so I feel like a popular
take from the left is that anyone who has a
moderate, even if it's a liberal viewpoint, is
therefore corrupt and therefore a shill. Hmm. Do
you believe that to be true? And how do you
tell the difference between the two? No.
Speaker 1: So you know that thing about like
you can, you know, porn when you see it? I think
people know grifter and enlightened centrist
positions when they see them versus someone
who's just moderate. I think there's a difference
between staking out positions of neutrality to be
perceived as some kind of, you know, above the
fray centrist. And it's often very disingenuous
and very transparent versus there are issues
on which people can just genuinely be moderate,
and it doesn't mean they've sold out to anyone.
There could be, you know, think about taxation.
There are people who might think that the top
tax rate should be 90 percent and some who think
there should be no taxes or a five percent flat
tax. And you're going to come across someone who
just thinks, Hey, look, I don't know, it should
be 42 percent a little bit higher than we have
now. But that's it just because they're at 42
and someone else is at 37 and someone else is
at 20. There's no particular reason to say if
you end up in the middle you, it's because of
a corrupting influence. There's no substantive
basis to believe that that's different than people
who just sort of frame themselves as neutral and
centrist on everything to pretend to be above
bias. You understand the distinction I'm making.
Speaker 7: Yeah, I do. And that's kind of how I
feel. I just it's just actually my comment was
more about the commentary of how other. Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Stream that because you're a moderate.
Yep. You are. Therefore, you are correct.
Speaker 4: No, I think
Speaker 1: I think that
Speaker 4: that's wrong. Yeah. You believe?
Speaker 1: No, I don't believe it either.
And I guess that's my point. There's no there's
no there's no substantive reason to assume that
because someone is moderate on an issue,
their view is corrupted by whatever. No,
I disagree with people who think that
whether they're on the left or right.
Speaker 7: Fair enough. And I do have a I have a
quick travel question for you because you again,
I call it a little bit a
while ago about travel stuff.
I have young kids. Where would you recommend
a foreign country that is more kid friendly?
Speaker 1: Oh my goodness, I have no idea.
What does it mean? Kid friendly? I mean,
there's millions of children in
countries all over the world.
Speaker 7: That is true. I guess my
thinking on that would be is, you know,
things that we as adults said to explore other
countries would be fine. Wouldn't that be fun
for a six year old? Right? I guess other places
where they would have things for kids as well
and not just, you know, old cultural stuff that
you and I would find interesting, but yeah,
a six or eight year old would
Speaker 4: I have no
Speaker 1: idea what a six or eight year old
finds? Interesting, to be perfectly frank,
I'm so poorly positioned to answer the question.
Speaker 7: No, that's fair. There's just more
of a fun question to ask you, and I have
one last quickie food debate. Sure, it is
autumn for whatever you prefer to call it. Sure.
Pumpkin spice or apple cider flavor?
Speaker 1: Oh my God. I don't do either,
but I will have an occasional cider
donut, so I guess I'd go cider
cider flavor rather than than pumpkin spice.
Speaker 7: It is a that's a fair point. I
thoroughly enjoy both, but I figured that
was, you know, you're from the Northeast.
I figured that. Be a big question for you.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. No, the pumpkin spice
stuff. I'm seeing everybody with their pumpkin
spice lattes that are half whipped cream with.
It's just it should be illegal. That's my view.
Speaker 7: I don't know. I turn to a very basic
white girl this time of year.
Speaker 4: So
all right, my friend on that way.
Speaker 1: But thank you very much for the
call. Likewise, yeah. Thanks very much. Yeah, no.
I, by the way, I don't think pumpkin spice should
be illegal. I just, you know, it's not, for me,
I guess, is the point that I'm trying to make.